[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATTHEW SULLIVAN: To kick
things off, show of hands.
Who's heard of Google Maps?
What a shock.
But show of hands for
who has heard of Flutter?
Wow, OK.
I don't even know why
we're giving this talk.
But how many of you have
an app in production
or near going into production?
There's a few, but not too many.
So we're going to
do two things today.
The first thing
we're going to do
is we're going to give
a quick whirlwind tour
of Flutter, why we think
it's good for building apps.
And we're going to take a
little peek under the hood.
We'll do that for
about 10, 15 minutes.
And then what we're going to
do is we are going to-- well,
Brett's going to
do some live coding
and sling some code onstage.
And he's going to combine two
of his favorite things, which
are--
BRETT MORGAN: Ice
cream and Maps.
Flutter and Maps, sorry.
MATTHEW SULLIVAN: It is
actually ice cream and Maps.
There we go.
And live coding is always
much more exciting for you,
possibly, not for us.
So we're going to get through
the slides very quickly.
And then we're going to the
meat and the bones of the topic.
OK.
So for those of you
who may not know--
there are very few of you in
the audience-- what is Flutter?
Well, Flutter lets
you build this.
This is an app, runs
in iOS and Android.
And it's built from
a single codebase.
But if you take a
look at the app,
it's not your standard out of
the box buttons and dropdowns
and app bars and
everything else.
It has a pretty unique UI.
And it's got some pretty
interesting animations.
And really, that's
what Flutter is about.
It's not about building your
standard clone of an email app
or building that chat app that
looks like every other chat
app.
It's about building apps that
could look like other apps
but give you the power to be
able to customize and to create
something that you and
your designers would want.
So let's take a
quick look at why
we think Flutter is good for
doing these types of things.
Well, first off-- and you're
going to see the term "native"
here a lot.
And it's very overloaded.
So I'll try to be specific.
And here, when I'm
talking about native UIs,
I'm talking about--
for those of you
with iPhones, when you're
scrolling something,
you're scrolling behavior is
going to feel like your iPhone.
It's going to drop down a bit.
It's going to bounce
back up again.
And for those of
you on Android, it's
going to have that
little inkwell effect,
that when you navigate
from screen to screen,
the two platforms
behave differently.
And so that's what we mean
by native UX, native UI
on each of those devices.
And Flutter gives you
this out of the box.
This is the same
app, same code base.
But you see, they are
behaving in different ways.
They're behaving appropriately
to the platform on which they
are running.
And you get this out of the box.
And Flutter takes
care of it for you.
Quick, interesting
fact, everything you see
here and in every
Flutter app, Flutter
is rendering 100% of
the pixels on screen,
which means the buttons
and the app bars,
they're not rendered by Android,
they're not rendered by iOS.
They're rendered by Flutter.
And we have built a large
collection of widgets
to enable you to do this.
And I'll explain more why
we did that in a little bit.
So we got native UIs.
That's great.
What we also have is we
have fluid and custom UIs.
And this is one
of the reasons why
we control the rendering
because since we've built
our own approximations of--
not approximations,
our own implementations
of the Material design spec
and Apple's UI specification,
which we call Cupertino, we
are able to not only implement
these but give you the ability
to heavily customize them
if you so desire.
And on top of that, because
we control the rendering,
we're able to optimize
these to be able to give you
the animations and the
60 frames per second
that you would expect.
This is kind of a no-brainer.
If you've got one
code base, and you're
building for two
platforms, you know,
you're going to get half the
cost if the time is equivalent.
And it's going to
cost you less money.
But that's not
really the point here
because one of the
things that we have done
and what we realize
is that giving you
an SDK out of the box is
only half the story because
for developers, what you need
is a really good set of tools
to be able to build apps
or software effectively.
And so we have built
a suite of tools.
And the one you see
up here is hot reload,
where when you edit a piece
of code and when you save it,
it is deployed and rendered
to the device in which you're
testing, be it an emulator
or an actual device
plugged in, in near real-time,
a second, two seconds,
maybe less than a second.
And so your development cycle
is very, very, very iterative.
And how does this translate
into what we in Google
have experienced?
Well, there is an app in Google
that we converted from iOS
and Android to Flutter.
Took about three or four
weeks to get engineers up
to speed in the Flutter
framework to understand it.
And once they did and started
to reimplement the app
and then get to the point
where the app was implemented
and add new features, it
was reported by metrics,
because we're Google, data, we
obviously gather a lot of it.
And when we looked at it,
we saw that the developers
were about two to three
times more productive
versus just one platform alone.
And on top of that, they
also got the other platform
included in that.
So we saw really significant
productivity gains,
which is why Flutter--
or which is why Google
invests in Flutter
because we get and see
real benefits from that.
So there we go.
There's a little bit of
marketing spiel about why
you should use Flutter.
That's great.
But let's look under
the hood a little bit
and see how some of these
things come to pass.
Well, first of
all, Flutter's tech
stack, the entire UI stack is
built in the Dart language.
There are many reasons
why we use Dart.
And I'll cover a few
of them later on.
But we have built the
entire UI stack in Dart.
And because Flutter
is open-source,
all your developers
have full access
to the source code of that
UI, those UI elements, which
means you can go
in and you can see
how we implemented a button.
And you can take that.
And you can change it.
You can modify it.
You can build your own
and be inspired by it
or do something different.
But the entire source
code, it's like having
the blueprint in front of
you to be able to implement
your own UI tools.
As well as that, you
see we have layered it,
which means if you
want Material or you
want Cupertino out
of the box, just use
the widgets that we give you.
But if you want to
go a little lower
and you want to change
the buttons to be
a little different or your
app bar behave differently,
you can drop down a layer.
And you can customize there.
Or you can drop
further, play around
with the different animations,
or drop even further and handle
all the painting and
rendering yourself,
which is why with Flutter, it
is very straightforward to be
able to customize to a
very high degree your UI.
So that's great.
Our engine is built in C++.
And it runs on the Skia
rendering engine, which
is an open-source project.
And other projects, such
as Chromium, use it.
And so we use this.
This is a highly-optimized
engine for drawing 2D graphics.
And it is available across
a large number of platforms.
And the reason why we
use it is because there
is a great implementation
of Skia for Android,
a great implementation of Skia
for iOS that we can compile to,
we can compile to them.
But because we have
an engine embedder,
we can potentially deploy
to other platforms.
So there is an experimental
engine embedder
for Flutter for Mac OS, which
you can go and get on our wiki,
I think?
BRETT MORGAN: It's
on the GitHub, yep.
MATTHEW SULLIVAN:
It's on the GitHub.
There is a great
post we did in Medium
which describes how to build
an engine embedder for Linux.
So Flutter, at the moment,
we're focusing on mobile.
We're making sure the Android
and iOS experiences are great.
But there is the
potential to have Flutter
run on other platforms as well.
Another reason why we
use Dart, we didn't just
pick it out of a hat and go,
oh, there's the Dart language.
We'll use that.
One of the reasons
why we did it is Dart
has a great compiler chain.
And so what that means is when I
showed you hot reload earlier--
and you're going to see
Brett use that heavily--
you saw code change and then
the actual implementation
of the app change on the
device in near real-time.
And the reason we can
do that is because Dart
has a virtual machine.
And when you're in debug
mode, we can take your app,
put it on the phone.
We can take your virtual
machine, put it on the phone.
And every time you
change your code,
we can inject that code straight
into the virtual machine.
And boom, it's
running on the device.
That sounds wonderful,
but virtual machines
come at a cost in
terms of performance
and come at a cost in terms
of the size of your app, which
isn't ideal when you're going
to be deploying to production.
But Dart gives this other means
of being able to compile it.
So that was our
[INAUDIBLE] implementation.
We have ahead-of-time compiler,
which will take your Flutter
and Dart code and
will compile it down
to native machine
code on the device.
We have our machine
code on iOS and Android.
And it is running
on the bare metal.
We don't need a
VM at that point.
lot of the tooling
we've built for debugging
and profiling your app.
We strip it all out.
And it becomes
much, much smaller.
So you get the best
of both worlds.
Dart gives us the
ability to go, hey,
give us an amazing
developer experience
and, hey, streamline
us to the n-th degree
so we can run as fast as we
can for users in production.
And developer tools, if
you use Android Studio
IntelliJ-- fantastic plugin.
We maintain it ourselves.
If you use, like myself,
Visual Studio Code, fantastic
plugin which we
maintain ourselves.
But the infrastructure we've
built for these platforms
is available for the developers.
So if you want to go
out there and build
an integration
for vim, which has
been done by some of the
engineers on the Flutter team,
or you want to
build it for Emacs
or any of the other IDEs,
that's entirely possible.
We have full terminal
support for those
who like to live in
the command line,
for those who like to have
continuous integration servers.
I've mentioned hot reload.
And we have a great
package manager.
So when you're pulling in your
first-party and third-party
packages and
libraries and plugins,
we are able to take
care of the versioning,
pull in the right pieces
for you to make that happen.
We have platform
channels, which allows
you to integrate with
existing Android and iOS code,
be it Java, Kotlin,
Swift, and Objective--
I got them all.
BRETT MORGAN: Objective C, yep.
MATTHEW SULLIVAN: And
we can go the other way.
And you can add Flutter
to existing apps.
So for those of you out there
who go, this sounds fantastic.
Flutter is great.
But we've already
invested years of time
building our apps
on both platforms.
You are able to integrate that.
And we've seen a
lot of people take
that route, where they
have a small portion
of their app in Flutter.
They tie it into
their existing apps.
Then over time, they can
transfer more or less of it
into Flutter and still get,
for at least that portion,
a single code base
on which to run it.
I'm going to very quickly talk
about how UIs are composed
because Brett's going to be
diving through a bunch of code.
And I just want to give
you a flavor now so you
don't get lost in the rush.
Here is an app.
It's got some images and
some icons and whatnot.
But how is Flutter actually--
how do you as a developer
or how are your developers
going to build for this?
Well, let's take a look.
OK.
So these things seem to be laid
out vertically to begin with.
So Flutter has the
concept of a column.
And we can wrap our UI
widgets in a column.
And then here's the thing.
Pretty much everything in
Flutter, bar a few exceptions,
are widgets.
And typically, when
you think of widgets,
you go UI components,
button, app bar, icon, text.
But in Flutter, layout
is also a widget.
So in your code, you're
actually defining
the layout, which can
be jarring for people
who are coming from--
excuse me, coming from
things like Xamlon Windows
or XML layouts in
Android because you're
used to that separation.
But what we've found
is because of the way
Dart structures its code
and because of the way
the Flutter SDK is
structured, it is actually
very readable and
very maintainable
and gives you things
like hot reload
and very maintainable
for the code given.
So there we go, vertical,
wrap it in a column.
That's great.
Well, the thing at
the top of the column
is probably an image.
That's not too interesting.
But then we take a look at this.
And this is kind of interesting.
There's a few things
going in here.
So let's take a closer look.
So it looks like we have
our text on one side.
And we have an icon and a
number on the other side.
So that's a horizontal layout.
We can wrap that in a row.
It looks like our text
expands to fill the space.
So we can wrap that
in an expanded.
And then if you
think about the text,
there's one on top of the
other, internally in that,
we can then wrap it in a column.
So you've got columns
and rows and columns.
And we have things like stacks.
And these may seem
very primitive
compared to potentially some
of the other types of layouts
you get elsewhere.
But we've found that just
using these primitives
and using them cleverly, we
are able to construct very
sophisticated UIs from these.
And it's very
straightforward to do that.
So when you look at
it, all you really
have here is a column of things.
And then when you come down to
your third row, for example,
it looks like you
have a row of icons.
And each of those is a
column with one or the other.
And that's how we
build things up.
We compose our UI
elements together.
And we lay them out
with the same code.
We have a full
set implementation
of Material design for
Flutter, unsurprisingly.
In fact our Material design
spec is highly inclusive.
We pretty much cover everything
that the spec defines.
So you can go in.
And you can build Material
design style apps very,
very easily.
And because the
new Material design
is designed to be
fairly flexible,
Flutter is ideally placed
to give you that flexibility
to be able to customize
and tweak these.
But sometimes you just want to
build an app that looks more
like a standard iOS app,
which is why out of the box
we also offer what we call
Cupertino widgets, which will
let you compose things
and put things together
in terms of more of
Apple's style of widgets.
And you can mix and match these.
And you can use
one or the other.
We're don't specify
it's all or nothing.
But we give you
these out of the box
so you have complete
choice as to how
you want to build your apps.
Two or three more slides, and
then Brett's on the spotlight.
But I want to talk very
briefly about cross platform
and our ecosystem.
So as I mentioned, if you have
a clump of Kotlin code or Java
code, and you have a
bunch of Swift code,
and you're like I've spent
ages building this code.
It does a lot of
the business logic.
It's fundamental to my business.
I don't want to rewrite this.
But I would really love to
use some of Flutter's UI
capabilities or extend
it with Flutter and Dart,
you can do that.
So we have the ability to
be able to do cross platform
RPC in both directions and
even have event channels
so you can stream events in
one direction or the other.
So you can have Android and
iOS code talk to Flutter code.
And as I said, you can do it
in the other direction as well.
We also have a great
ecosystem of packages.
Some of which we
maintain ourselves,
like Firebase plugins are us,
the WebView and Maps plugins
are us.
We do Camera.
We do a bunch of
things that we feel
are critical to the platform.
But the community has
stepped up and added
tons of other packages
and plugins out there.
And you can go to that website.
In fact, you can just do
Flutter Packages, Google that.
And you will get to this site.
And you can just see
the range of packages
that are available to
you out of the box,
which will save
you time building.
But the idea here is that
Dart's been around for a while.
Flutter's fairly new.
But we already have a rich
ecosystem of Dart code.
And our Flutter ecosystem
is growing steadily
to the point where we have
over 1,400 Flutter packages
in our pub system today.
Flutter is completely
open-source.
Every line of code is in
github.com/flutter/flutter
or github.com/flutter/engine.
You can go there.
You can see how
everything is built.
And we take contributions
externally all the time.
There's over 300 contributors to
the Flutter repository and code
base itself.
In fact, we've gotten so popular
that we're ranked pretty highly
now in terms of popularity
for GitHub repos.
There are thousands
of apps written
in Flutter that have been
published to the Play
Store and the App Store.
Google has published a few.
The community has
published thousands more.
We'll show you-- we'll
give you a taste of who's
doing what towards the end.
But Flutter is ready for
use in production today.
It has been for a long time.
The app we always
used to talk about,
Hamilton, is like
a year and a half
more since it was
first put out there.
And since then,
we've gone to beta.
We're at 1.0, we're at 1.2
at the moment, I believe.
And so we have a solid, stable
platform that we in Google
rely on and that we feel that
you can rely on to provide
services to your users.
Our community is awesome.
We love our community.
They're very inclusive.
And they have a ton
of areas in which you
can start with Flutter.
If you go to
flutter.dev/community,
we have a bunch of
community links there.
We do things like
startflutter.com,
flutter.institute.
We have fantastic documentation,
I feel, on flutter.dev.
The community has
produced so much more.
So if you want to
learn about Flutter,
there is some starting points.
But I think I have
waffled on enough.
So without further ado,
what could possibly go wrong
with your live coding demo?
[LAUGHTER]
BRETT MORGAN: So if we could
transfer to the demo computer,
and let's see how much of a fool
I can make of myself on stage.
Here we are.
So here we are.
We're starting with your
traditional hello world app.
What we're going to build
today is an application
to let us roam around the ice
cream stores of San Francisco.
It seemed like a great idea
while I was sweltering away
in the Australian heat.
But now that I've
come to San Francisco
and it's all kinds of
cold, and I'm sort of like,
I should have done
coffee instead.
MATTHEW SULLIVAN: Yeah.
There's a reason why I have
my woolly hat on today.
BRETT MORGAN: Yeah, totally.
So, growing up in
Australia, ice cream stores
use this palette
of pastel colors.
And so blue and white, it's
not really doing it for me.
So the first thing
we're going to change,
so we're going to
change the color.
And what you've seen there is
I've made a change to the code,
saved it to disk.
Flutter has noticed.
And it's hot reloaded the app.
And as you saw,
it's pretty quick.
So the obvious
question is, if I've
got a list of ice cream stores,
where are we going to store it?
Well, being a cloud
conference, of course,
I'm going to go with
Google Cloud Firestore.
And the first step in
including functionality
is we import it at
the top of the file.
Now, the next step is I'm
going to turn around and make
a quick change to
the application.
And something really
amazing is going to happen.
MATTHEW SULLIVAN: You-- in two
minutes, you broke the app.
Well done.
Congratulations.
Round of applause for my--
BRETT MORGAN: OK, I'm done.
MATTHEW SULLIVAN: --the app.
Yay!
There we go.
[APPLAUSE]
BRETT MORGAN: So before
we run away in horror,
it's actually trying to tell
us something interesting.
Type HomePage is not a
subtype of StatelessWidget.
So what's happened
here is initially,
this was a StatelessWidget.
I'm hoping that wasn't
my phone beeping.
Anyway, it was a
StatelessWidget.
And we've turned it
into a StatefulWidget
because I need it to
actually have some state.
And Flutter has
gone, I can't quite
figure out what you're doing
here, help me out here.
And the fairly easy
way of helping it out
is turning around
and reloading it.
And we're up and running again.
Again, reloading
takes longer than--
sorry-- am I using my
phrase incorrectly?
MATTHEW SULLIVAN: [INAUDIBLE].
BRETT MORGAN: Reloading is a
bit slower, but not that slower.
MATTHEW SULLIVAN: So one
of the things to see here
is that, like, the app broke.
And it's not
immediately obvious why.
And that's because one of
the benefits of hot reload
is that it maintains state.
So if you're five
screens down in your app
and you're tweaking
your UI and whatnot,
you don't have to
renavigate back there
every time you save your code.
What happened here, though,
is that Brett actually
changed the code which
maintains the state.
And once you do that, Flutter is
not smart enough to kind of go,
I'm good, and that automagically
make your state recover.
And so we have to do
a hot restart, which--
BRETT MORGAN: Thank you.
MATTHEW SULLIVAN: --is
a second and a half
versus 700 milliseconds.
But it kills your state.
BRETT MORGAN: Cool.
So the reason I did this
is that I'm actually
doing the idiomatic thing
when creating state.
I'm creating a stateful object.
And so HomePage is
a StatefulWidget.
And it has a partner object
called HomePageState.
And when this object
is created, it's
turning around and making
a connection to Firestore.
And we're doing a
query against Firestore
where we're looking at the
collection of ice cream stores
and ordering them by their name.
Now that I've got this
query, I can actually
turn around and start using it.
So what I'm doing is
I've got a StreamBuilder.
I pass that StreamBuilder
to my stream.
And a stream, for those
of you who aren't aware,
it's kind of the lovechild
of futures and lists
where it's this list that
goes off into the future.
And each future
state is actually
a state of the database.
So someone makes a change
in the Cloud Firestore,
adds another ice
cream store, it will
turn around and update the app.
And we'll go from 14
ice cream stores to 15.
MATTHEW SULLIVAN:
So one of the things
that people might see here is
this seems a little complicated
with streams and asynchronous.
What are they talking about?
One of the strengths of Dart and
one of the strengths of Flutter
is it's asynchronous
in its very nature.
It means you don't
have to spin up threads
to handle things like
network calls or whatnot
or to handle like I/O basically.
And what you can do with it
is it's very easy for Brett
in a few lines of
code here to say,
here is the stream of
data from Firestore.
Here is the StreamBuilder.
And this app, with
a few lines of code,
will update itself every
time that data store changes.
So if we go in and we add
new things to the database,
that's going to be reflected
in the app automatically.
And it will rebuild itself with
no additional work from you.
BRETT MORGAN: Yes.
And of course, knowing
you, that you're all
quite interested in
ice cream stores,
I went ahead and did
the next step, which
is instead of just saying we've
got 14 stores, I turn around,
and I've created a ListView.
And so we've got
this ListView here.
We've got a bunch of stores.
Here's a part of Dart
syntax that I quite like.
We have a thing called
named constructors.
So I'm constructing an
object called ListView.
But I'm constructing
it in a specific way
where I give it a builder.
So I'm effectively
creating the ListTiles.
But I'm only creating them
on an as needs basis, which
means that if I have, say,
a really long list of data,
I only create the
appropriate parts that
are being shown on the screen,
saving us CPU, saving us
memory.
One of the great things
that Matt mentioned earlier
is that when you have all of
your Flutter code as code,
you get the ability to
turn around and pull out
abstractions and name things.
So I've got this
ListView.builder,
but to me, I really
wanted to call it
a StoreList, which means that
my build method for my state
object now just goes,
OK, I've got a StoreList.
And I've simplified
that complexity
so that when I'm
reading this code later,
I'm not turned
around and overloaded
with a whole bunch
of stuff and I
can't see hide nor hair of
what I was trying to do.
And the reason I'm doing this,
it leads into the next thing.
The list of cream
stores, wouldn't it
be nice to have a map?
So the first step, obviously,
import the functionality.
Now, the next one
is going to chew up
a bit of time as my computer
types everything in for me.
So who here has done CSS
three star Flexboxes?
Couple of you?
Oh, good.
We've got some web developers.
So you'll be pleased to
know that-- oh, yeah.
Remember how I said, we
had a StoreList before?
We went through and built that.
I built a matching
StoreMap, which is
built on top of a Google Map.
And we'll add some more
code to that in a minute.
But the part I'm talking
about is here in the column,
this column replaces
the earlier thing
where we just had a StoreList.
And because this column is
made up of two flexibles,
40% at the top is the Google
Map, which is this part here,
and 60% down here
is our list, given
that we have 2 and 3 which add
up to 5, 2/5, 3/5, 40%, 60%.
So that's cool.
We've got a map.
We've got a list of
ice cream stores.
Wouldn't it be nice to
actually, oh, I don't know,
put some markers on the
map where all the ice cream
stores are?
[LAUGHTER]
MATTHEW SULLIVAN: Fans of
ice cream in the audience.
Excellent.
BRETT MORGAN: Boom.
We have some ice cream stores.
So we can click on them.
And they've got titles.
And that's all good stuff.
But, you know, what
would be really
nice is if I could
click down here and go
to the actual store.
OK.
Let's include some
more functionality.
And this time, I'm
including dot async
Why am I including dot async?
OK, so what am I creating here
is a thing called a completer.
And a completer is an
asynchronous communication
channel.
Because I have an
interesting problem in that
I want this list
down at the bottom
here, when I click on
it, to control the map.
And the map gives us a way to
do it, a GoogleMapController.
But the map, Google Map,
doesn't give it to us
until after it's on the screen,
which is too late to hand it
to the ListView.
So effectively, I'm handing the
ListView this sort of token.
This says, some
point in the future,
this thing will resolve or
complete to a Google Map.
So let's turn around
and do some more typing.
And here's the important part.
When the map is
created, we turn around
and complete that completer
with a Google Map.
But because I've created
things out of order,
I just need to reload my app.
Our completer is now loaded.
Let's turn around and
fill in the StoreList.
So we're adding
some functionalities
to this abstraction
such that when
we tap on one of
the ListTiles, it
will turn around and go to the
latitude and longitude of where
that store is.
So let's say we want to go
to CREAM San Francisco, yes!
We're done, right?
MATTHEW SULLIVAN: Are we?
Good.
BRETT MORGAN: Oh, OK.
Let's do it some more.
MATTHEW SULLIVAN: 22
minutes left to go.
Sounds good.
This didn't go so smoothly.
And we practiced
it earlier today.
BRETT MORGAN: What
would be really nice,
we've got a list of stores.
It'd be nice to use some photos.
So alongside the name of the
place, the location, the street
address, I've got a place ID.
And talking earlier,
we mentioned the fact
that we have a whole bunch of
community-maintained packages.
And there's a package called
google_maps_webservice,
which gives us access to the
Google Maps web service APIs.
In this case, I'm going to be
using the Places API to look up
information about
these ice cream stores.
We have things
like opening times,
reviews, all that sort of stuff.
The part I'm going to
be using is the photos.
So the first thing I need to do
is, of course, refactor things.
I'm creating a store
ListTile that has state.
So it's got to store
this tile state.
And we're going to
turn around and use
that to remember things once we
make calls to the Places API.
Let's do that now.
And we'll turn around and we'll
create a Places API client
that we'll make requests over.
I have to make a
quick comment here
because I was the Maps developer
relations for so many years.
Do not put your Google Maps
API key in a production app.
Don't distribute it.
When you're doing quick
demos on screen, that's OK.
Don't do it with production.
Just saying.
Because I created
the state objects
and then added the init state, I
just need to do a quick reload.
And we'll get a whole
bunch of photos.
Now we're done, right?
MATTHEW SULLIVAN:
We are done, right?
No?
BRETT MORGAN: No.
I'm going to do one more thing.
MATTHEW SULLIVAN:
One more thing?
BRETT MORGAN: Always
one more thing, right?
MATTHEW SULLIVAN:
Thanks, Martin.
BRETT MORGAN: So given
the fact that we've
created all these
abstractions, we've
got ListTiles and Google
Maps and all these sorts
of things, what
I'm going to do is
I'm going to replace the
ListView down on the bottom
by replacing just that
StoreList abstraction
with a StoreCarousel.
It'll turn the page
into a full screen map.
I have a carousel of
tiles across the top
that we can click on.
It's almost finished typing.
I love-- ooh--
I broke it again.
So one of the fun things is
because I have this completer
and I've completed it twice
because I reparented the map,
it's getting cranky at me.
So you won't see
this in production.
But just because of the way
I've been building it live,
it now works.
So we can turn around
and click on it.
That's Mission Delores Park.
That looks like Bi-Rite to me.
And now we're done.
MATTHEW SULLIVAN:
Does that carousel
actually scroll, because--
BRETT MORGAN: Oh, yes.
Yes.
Most important part.
MATTHEW SULLIVAN: I mean.
BRETT MORGAN: There we go.
MATTHEW SULLIVAN: That's the
impressive piece of your demo.
And you completely forgot.
So that's really cool.
How many lines of code
did that take in total.
BRETT MORGAN: So let's go back
to the right file this time.
And less than 250 lines of code.
[APPLAUSE]
Back to the slides.
MATTHEW SULLIVAN: So we threw
a lot of code at you there.
And we went through a whole
bunch of coding pieces.
But that was real code.
That was it actually
hot reloading.
That was it breaking
when things break.
And the idea here is that
we went from like zero
to about 150 lines of--
250 lines of code,
having multiple different
representations, showing
the composability,
showing how we can reuse pieces,
and showing the power of things
like Dart's asynchronicity
to make it easy to construct
and build these apps.
Because you've seen a
lot of code on there,
but when you sit down
and you look at it
and you work through
it, it's actually
fairly elegant,
maintainable-- at least
I think so-- and readable.
BRETT MORGAN: Yes.
MATTHEW SULLIVAN:
So hopefully, that's
given you a little bit
of a flavor for what
it's like to work with
Flutter and to integrate it
in things like Google Maps.
There are a bunch
of people much more
on this slide that
are using Flutter
in production in various ways.
We are, obviously.
Groupon, Square, Tencent,
Alibaba, all of them
are either using
Flutter to build
100% Dart and Flutter
apps or are using Flutter
inside their existing apps.
And there is a wide range of
uses across all of our users.
But we're seeing that
companies like these,
hopefully, are trusting the
technology because these things
are deployed across hundreds
of millions of devices
at this moment in
time around the world.
So if this takes
your fancy, we highly
recommend go to flutter.dev.
We've got a couple of
starting tutorials.
If you're new to Flutter,
go and check it out.
See if it's for you.
And with that, we will
open it up for questions.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]